こんにちははじめ社長です月日はもう2月気付けばもうすぐ
バーレーン対んでそこをもらう1チョコをあげる人
もらえそうな人いますか僕はいません今ないですね皆さん kitkat ご存じ
でしょうかあの赤いパッケージのキットカットてもご存知だと思うんですけども
今回そのキットカットを作っている音ズレさんが画期的なサービスを開発したらしい
です
なんと実際にそのサービスを使うことによってバレンタイン地方
ねだりしたり折ったりすることができるらしいです口は大敵でこちらですね
バレンタインポスト延滞ポッターバーチャルたチョコを簡単に贈りあえるサービスこれ
ね結構いいと思うんだよねー
実際多分ほどそこにいただければ恥ずかしいって音だろいると思うからそういう黄金
キャッシュにね高級物を伝えたいときに一人くさいつってもいいとかなって思います
ん
これなら遠くの人にも近くの人にもチョコが送りあえちゃうでということで
ポスターので遠くに想いを伝えたい人はいるんだったらこのバレンタイン pos で
ちょっと
送っちゃってもいいのかなと思います本物のチョコを貰えるチャンスも早速コストを
作ってみようというわけで何度これバーチャルだけじゃなくてひょっとしたら本物の底
にともらえる可能性もあるみたいです皆やってみてください
出て
さっそくやってみましょう twitter でつくるどんなポストにする
いろんなポストがいるわけですねもっとボイ友達大好きチョコ大好き誰にでもすぐお
ねだりするよ
だけでもいいのか思いは一ついるんだこそ買えるんですけどぼかぁ
熱血ポストでいきますなんか頑張っている感じが好きです
このポストにしましょう追い風でポストを作りますスポットをシェアしてチョコお
ねだりしよう
でこれで facebook twitter line deco の画像がシェア
されます
はいもうツイートしたらおりですこんな感じになりますみんな
中国ビアーそしてさらに今回は私の誕生日記念として特別企画
この僕にあのリアルなチョコをくれてみたいです
なるほどなそれをイースホットほんとそれをいです家で直を北に遅れてみたいなんです
けどちょっとやってみましょう
バレンタインポストのでここだ僕ですね人気いい中盤でチョコを贈ろう
子供だ夫詳しい送り方がわかるので是非皆さん見てみてくださいお待ちしております
さーてバレンタイン
素でおねだりもしです
ないけどそれってくれねーかなー
[音楽]
ん
こんなに送られてきましたスパた子は何でもてるんだ
バッハ
ハーモ時過ぎでもて席が仕方ないぜ
嘘です本当はねセレさんから頂きましたらほんとありがとうございますでもそれにして
も多いなぁ
特にきっとハット線ことはこちらキットカットショコラトリーサブリムビターが100
個
送られてきましたところ取り supreme vita を食べたこのにちょっと
食べてみます i 恋など高級感あふれるパッケージですね大
キットカットですねいただけます
うーんうまいうまいぞめちゃくちゃ甘いってわけじゃないんですけどほのかに甘くて
合う大人の味わいでしたねピーターが美味しくかつあるということは私も大人になっ
たら
打ち出すやっぱりチョコレートクープ元気が出るなぁ
アーキヴォイスる全部食べませんかいというわけでですね一人だとこれだけの量の
チョコレートは食べきれないのでちょっと今ここにあるチョコレート僕が今
電気を渡したい人たちが今チョコレートその人たちに届けたいと思いますみなさんいう
フェスというイベントはご存じでしょうか去年から全国を回っててそれのラフとか東京
で行われま
ねぼく知ってるんですよ僕とが参加者のクリエイターさんももちろんなんですけども
その裏で僕の事務所で働いている社員さんやイベントの関係者の皆さん裏方のスタッフ
普段見えない人たちがすごい努力して初めて成り立っているイベントでございます普段
表には出ないで裏方で頑張ってくださっている皆様に
僕は最後元気を渡したいと思っているので
ここにあるチョコレート全部渡すわけにはいきません
0たしませんこっちなぁかいもうね前この部分は僕が友達とか頭を食べる分でして
こっちのチョコレート良いサーブムービーちゃーん残り99個あるのでこちらの99
この30分ビターン
いうフェスのスタッフ皆様に配っていきたいとおもいますメルバ光線で頑張っている方
もいるみたいなので
甘いチョコレートを食べて少しでも元気を出してくれればと思いますでは
する行ってきまーすと
はいというわけで竜舌の会場につきましたキットカットを配っていきたいとおもいます
さっそく1人目がいつも疲れたので
かせていきましょういつもお疲れ様ですねーからのよという方が食べてください
外ことがうれしいありがとうございます
いつも使うのでありがとうございますリーダー道重ん
ぜひ食べています全部たらしい
おお疲れ様ですありがとうございます鎌田さんよろしくお願い
うんうちイケメンですいつもつけると思うよありがとうございますか
あれ
[音楽]
んっ
持った
tan
me
ありがとうございますいただきますすみません
はいだけで無事全部配り切りました皆さん喜んでくれて良かったです本当にお疲れ様
ですそしてですねいつもどうぞ見てくださってる皆さんにも私からバーチャルチョコを
贈りたいと思います動画の説明欄にある url をクリックすると受け取ることが
できますぜひ皆さん受け取ってください
たくさんの方に受け取ってもらえると嬉しいです特にだし私からの
バレンタインプレゼントよ ua アイテムで皆さん私が今日紹介したバレンタイン
ポスト
絶対言ってチョコレートなぁで渡せないとかべチョコレだっていらねー c みたいな
ちょっと突っ張ってる女子は男子の皆さん想いを伝えてみてはいかがでしょ
ぜひ皆さんも通行をゲットしてもらえると嬉しいですじゃなく
me
ni
あっはっ